Bondservants obey your earthly masters with fear and trembling with a sincere heart as he would Christ
Not by the way of eye service as people pleasers
But as bondservants of Christ doing the will of God from the heart
Rendering service with a good will as to the Lord and not to man
Knowing that whatever good anyone does this he will receive back from the Lord whether he is a bondservant or is free
Masters do the same to them and stop your threatening knowing that he who is both their master and yours is in heaven and that there is no partiality with him
Thank you so much
And we are grateful for the Lord's word and
Let's let's come to it prayerfully. I think the Lord would speak to us here
So we'll thank you for your word
We do pray that you would speak to us now for your servants are listening in Jesus name
Author Annie Dillard once wrote some poignant words. She said how we spend our days
Is of course how we spend our lives?
What we do with this hour and that one is what we are doing
So how we spend our hours is how we're spending our lives
So
Remembering that quote made me think well, how are we actually spending our hours particularly in a North American context?
and so I asked chat GPT if if they could inform me about that and
Here's what they came up with and this is not the full layout
But just if the rough average lifespan is about 78 years, you'll spend six months of those years waiting in line
You will spend the one to two of those years commuting you will spend two of those years grooming
some less
No comment
You'll spend about three of those years on vacation
About three or four years socializing with friends and family
But here's the point I was wanting to really find out is you will spend about ten point three of those years at work
So that's about 90,000 hours on average that Americans will spend across their lifetime at work
So that's 20% of your waking life being spent at work
Whether or not that is a healthy number of hours is a subject for another day just out of curiosity
I also asked chat GP
Chat GPT if it looked any different in Europe and the hours did vary quite wildly when it came to that
Well, that's another subject for another day
But whatever will work looks like for you and whatever the hours you're putting in a huge portion of most of our lives
We'll be spent working in one way or another and that includes work in the home as well as work
outside the home and
if that's the case and it is
Then surely Christian discipleship can't just be about what we do in the evenings and on the weekends
Although sometimes we speak or maybe even think about discipleship as being what we're doing like on the evenings or weekends
Or first thing in the morning
We might think of it as going to church and having a quiet time like that is following Jesus
But then have a separate category in our minds for what we're doing when we are at work
Don't get me wrong things like going to church and reading your Bible regularly are
foundational and they feed into everything that we are doing but that is not where our discipleship ends we are called to follow
Christ in our work as well as unto him
Fact is if Jesus is Lord of all and he is then discipleship
includes all of life
And includes the every day it includes our work
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna see what scripture says about work in this text
But we cannot look at the issue of work in this text in particular without looking at the glaring issue of
Slavery that is before us here in this passage as we're reading it reading about slaves and masters
We can't help but ask the question is scripture requiring or even supporting
Slavery here. Is that what's going on in this passage?
Well, the answer is a resounding no
And if you read the Bible carefully you actually have good reasons to be
against slavery or other kinds of
things like segregation or any form of racism and
You have grounds in ways that other worldviews do not give you grounds
To be against those things. So what do I mean?
Well, let's let's as we look at this passage
We need to do a couple of things one is we need to understand it historically especially in the context of the Roman Empire
So this is being written in a context that we're we would have been nearly
Impossible to conceive of a world without slavery. I mean think of a world without electricity
Electricity like it's just the world we inhabit and that was the case if you're growing up in the Roman Empire
Slavery was pervasive a significant percentage of the population was made up of slaves
There's different estimates, but some estimate of something like 10 to 20 percent of the entire Empire was made up of
slaves and those who were enslaved were a wide range of people and
Now to be clear it was not
Race-based slavery like you get in the antebellum south in more recent centuries a range a range of people across a wide spectrum of
Societies a society became slaves for different reasons like they might have had a debt to pay off
And they couldn't pay it so they became a slave or maybe they were born into it
And there's all kinds of reasons why people would become slaves and so it was not race-based
So slaves existed and worked across society in a wide array of sectors then so you see it across a
Lots of different jobs that people would have been given to do
Now and their treatment varied
Now there are ways in which it was it was better than the slavery
We might think of in terms of American slavery or British slavery in the past
And I've almost I've heard that before just used to like dismiss like it wasn't as bad
So so don't worry about it. It was still really bad. I mean when you look at what was going on
It was awful. I mean some were treated better than others, but it was still pretty terrible people were viewed and treated as
property it was awful
So slavery was still
bad news
So we need to understand this historically so that's the context that Paul is writing to but we also need to understand the context
scripturally as well
So elsewhere in scripture you can read about the practice of enslaving people or
Trafficking in slavery as being sinful it is it is named a simple more than once so first Timothy chapter 1 and verse 10
Speaks about the sin of enslaving others
You can read the book of Philemon and there you see that Philemon was a slave owner
And he is instructed to receive back a runaway slave of his but no longer as a slave
But now as a brother in Christ
So he's to treat this former slave now as a brother in
Christ
And you can also read in 1st Corinthians chapter 7 in verse 21 where slaves were encouraged to avail themselves of the opportunity
To become free if it presented themselves
presented itself so if a slave had an opportunity to gain their freedom Paul says you should take it
So he's encouraging people towards freedom
But what the Bible says here as well as elsewhere and I think this is an important point to realize is it is it undermines
slavery and
It will eventually lead to the undoing of slavery
So although Paul isn't going right in and saying like this is wrong
You should be dead against this what he is saying is going to undermine it completely
So what you see in scriptures that everyone has inherent dignity
Why because they are created in the image of God and they should be treated with the dignity that comes with that
We also see
The equality of all people in scripture. So so look at even verse 9 in our text
He gives us long list of things to bond servants or slaves
But then when you get to verse 9 he says masters and you could totally skip over this or just not see what he's saying
All that I've just said to slaves
masters do the
Same to them
That's remarkable
Shocking it's really striking
Treat them in the same way
So while Paul is recognizing in their kind of workforce there their structure
They might have different roles and jobs to carry out
He treats them as equals and calls upon them to do the same for one another
He then ends by saying there is no partiality with God
God doesn't favor anyone above another on the basis of their social status or ethnicity or anything else and neither should we
So there's a call to
Treating others as equals so the gospel changes the way that we view not only God and ourselves
But also others we treat others with
dignity and
Equality and the respect that comes with that
Now you read that historically Christians will then go on to oppose the institution of slavery in the Roman Empire
You can read early in the early church sermons preached against slavery while it was still being practiced
Was that then you then have the demise of slavery then it kind of comes back again with the Atlantic slave trade later on
But then you get examples like William Wilberforce. I'm gonna read about him
He came campaigned his entire working career
Against the slave trade and it wasn't till right near the end of his life that finally
People had come on board with what he'd been saying all along and did away with the slave trade and what drove him to be so against it was
His Christian faith and you can read all about that
We could think of many other examples as well of people's Christian faith driving them towards
equality
so today
We are living in a cultural context that rightly
appreciates the good that has come through the influence of Christianity like the dignity and equality of all people at the same time
We're living in a cultural moment where we're wanting to like divorce it from its origins
Like we're not thinking about how did we get here to where we actually
Value others in that way as opposed to practicing things that have been practiced through the centuries before like
slavery
It's it's it's
It's like we're enjoying
Artimates talking about it's like we're enjoying a flower that's been plucked up from its roots
It's like this is really great, you know the the dignity of all people we really value equality
This is beautiful, but where has that come from on what basis do we treat other people in that way?
And it goes back into who God is how he has made us the difference that the gospel has made in people's lives
And that being worked through in society, but if we've plucked up from the roots
How long is it going to last where things going to lead?
So it's important that we value these things, but also that we know why
So the apostle Paul here and to just kind of draw all that together is not speaking about how
Society should be structured, but rather how to live within the structures that already exist in a particular society
He's showing people how to live as
Christians in
Their particular circumstance that they're in historically
And so this was the case in the first century that you have this institution there
But it also speaks to our work life now
So while the workforce is
Rightly and it's great that it's structured differently now in the modern world
The truths that are laid before us here are still applicable
We can't say well Paul is just addressing his context and not addressing ours because what he says to slaves and masters
Speaks to employees and employers as well
So it speaks to all of us in the work that we are doing
So we're gonna pivot now and see what this passage says to us in our working conditions today in our context
So we're gonna see two things
one is we're gonna see
The as you go to work tomorrow morning say you should be remembering who you're working for and
The difference that working for them makes okay who you're working for the difference that that makes
Okay, so first of all who we are working for in every verse of our passage
Without exception you find the word
Christ or master or the Lord
So Christ is at the center of what he's saying here to bond servants and masters
So slaves are told that they do not ultimately belong to any earthly master. They belong to Christ
Verse six they are bond servants of Christ
Verse seven their work is to be done as unto the Lord
Verse eight their work is going to be hard
But their reward will ultimately come from the Lord you're working for him
So it goes on to masters
Treat them in the same way, okay
So there's everything that went before is being applied to them too, but he's also saying masters
You do not have the ultimate authority remember you to have a master and not only that
Those you are those who are working for you have the same master as you
So you're equals under Christ
Okay, so here we're seeing that Christ is the Lord of our work
And that shouldn't be surprising to us. So
Look at your Bible page one
What do we find God doing there in creation? He is working
When he creates us you literally turn to page two of your Bible at least now it's laid out in mind
You turn to page two he commands
Man to work so if God's work is the work of creation and it's work is the work of
Cultivation so working is happening there
So he creates us to work and then you have the fall that takes place now
We were working before the fall then after the fall work is in curse, but work itself is not a curse
It was affected by the fall it was cursed, but it is not a curse. It is part of God's good design
In how he created the world
We were made to work. So we should remember the Lordship of Christ over our work and
as we do that that means that
At least a couple liberating things are true
One is that it shows us that our work matters your work matters. It's even sacred
The Lord has given you this work. He's called you to work and to work for him. It's sacred work
So sometimes too sharp a distinction can be made between secular jobs and
Sacred jobs as though one was the Lord's work and the other was kind of like worldly work or something
It's like it's it's okay to work in education or commerce or medicine or whatever
But if you really want to do the Lord's work, well, that means you know being a missionary or a pastor or something like that
But you don't see that kind of sharp distinction here all work is the Lord's work for doing it has unto him
I don't know if you're familiar with Eric little you certainly hear more about him in the UK
But Eric little was a he was a British runner
He's known for his competing in the Olympics
He refused to to run on Sundays, but he wanted to honor the Lord
But even in spite of him refusing to run on Sundays, he ended up winning a gold medal
So that's that's part of his story, but he's also known for his mission work in China
so he spent the rest of his years as a missionary in China and
Just a really fascinating life to look at and if you if you're not familiar with him watch the movie chariots of fire
if you've not seen that so it's great movie and
In chariots of fire his sister Jenny
Is just trying to square like okay? You're you're gonna be running, but I thought the Lord had called you to be a missionary in China like
Well, yeah, how are you squaring that? I don't think that's how she said it in it
But she's trying to figure this out and he says something to her
In the in the film that really reflects how he viewed it
He said this he said I believe God has made me for a purpose
for China
But he also made me fast
And when I run I feel his pleasure
So both of those things were true at the same time. Yeah, he made me for purpose for china
He's calling me there, but he also made me fast and when I run I feel his pleasure
So in our text here, what do we see verse 7 that anyone who is doing their service as unto the Lord
Is doing his will
Sorry that wasn't verse 7 is in verse 6
You go back says do the will of God from the heart
So your work whatever it is is referred to as the will of God or his pleasure
So you can be doing the will of God living for his pleasure in a warehouse
You know stack of boxes whatever
Or out on the mission field
That's great if you can get a job, you know where your paycheck comes from that is in line with your gift
But that is not always the case
So whatever your work situation your work is part of your worship
And it is fulfilling the very will of God for your life now
It's one of the areas he is calling you to live for his good pleasure
If that was true for a slave like they're not wrestling like what's the will of God for my life
My in the right line of work or that sort of thing
He's saying what you're doing now is not the will of God
Now is the will of God right now for you to serve him where he has placed you
So your work matters to the Lord whatever it is
So it shows us that yeah our work matters, but it also shows us that our work isn't ultimate
So it's sacred, but it's not God. It's sacred, but it's not sovereign
So consciously working under the Lordship of Christ not only elevates our work. Yes, it dignifies it, but
It also dethrones it
Work is not ultimate Christ is
And we need to get a hold of that
Because if we get a hold of that that Christ is sovereign of our work
Then that means that we're not going to be looking to our work for our sense of
Identity or meaning or or value
If you view your work in that way it will enslave you that's that's real slavery
If you're looking for identity or meaning or value there, you're more likely to to overwork to to try to achieve it or
Or mistreat others in the process or neglect other areas of responsibility because you're really aiming at
That you're enthroning that
It's also a recipe for discouragement when things aren't working out as you hope
You can end up in this kind of like identity crisis when you over elevate your work
So we need to remember that the Lord is sovereign over work
He is our ultimate provider and we are there to serve
him
Um
Johann Sebastian Bach you've probably heard his music before even if you didn't know that's what you were listening to
But when he would begin his work as a composer he would start off what he was writing with writing music
We'd write a j and another j at the top of the page
Then we get to the end of composing he would then write a sdg
And the j and j at the top was yesu yufo, which means
jesus help
And then once he gets to the end of his work, he's writing sdg solely the glory
To god alone be the glory
So as i'm engaging in this work of writing music i'm saying lord i'm praying for your help
Because this is ultimately your work
And i'm giving you all the glory for what you have done
So knowing that we are working for jesus helps us to take our work seriously without the mistake of living for it
Identity meaning and fulfillment is found in the one we're working for
We're to work for his glory by the power of his spirit no matter what the job is
Okay, so that's who we're working for
I don't want to also see the difference that it makes i'll just we could list out a bunch of differences
But let's just draw out four from the passage
Okay, one difference that it makes is how we
View our obligations so the difference it makes to our obligations at work
So one of the things that paul tells workers here is to fulfill the obligations they have at work
He's going to give more attention to how they go about doing that their motivations
But he makes it clear that they're still called to actually do the work they're there to do
So verse five says servants
Obey your masters right fulfill your obligations
Verse seven you're to render service like you're there to work. So you've got to serve
So the same can then be inferred for those who are then managing others as well
They're to fulfill their obligations for those they are managing
In other words, but simply do the job you're there to do
What I was thinking about this creed bratton came to mind
Some of you are laughing some of you have no idea who I'm talking about this is not an all out endorsement of the office
Um, that's pretty funny and uh, and there's lots of interesting characters
But one of them is creed and and the whole thing with creed is like people don't really know exactly what he's
What his job is like he's just kind of the mysterious character in the back
Who somehow manages to evade any kind of question about who he is and what he is there to do
He's there to get away with as much as he can get away with with actually not working
Um
So while christians are not working to be seen we shouldn't be known for applying ourselves to the work
They're actually there to do like we're there to do a job and we get on with it
So ecclesiastes chapter nine verse 10 says whatever your hand finds to do
Do it with all your strength whatever it is you got a job
Apply yourself to it
What about when the things were given to do that aren't right that might come to our minds here
So all authority is under god's authority see that in romans 13
But that doesn't mean that everything somebody might call us to do is is just or right
So carrying out what your employer is asking you to do is not without restrictions because remember you're both under the same master
So if you're being asked to do something by an employer that is unjust
Will you have another master to obey and sometimes that might might mean disobeying
Another command that is given to you. So you got lots of examples of this in scripture
So exodus chapter one the midwives were told to
Kill the baby boys that were being born in egypt, but they refused to do that the lord blesses them
And they have daniel three shadrech mishik and abendigo. They're refusing to bow down and worship the statue
of of nebuchadnezzar
So when we're being asked to do something that is unjust
Could be i don't know a teacher being asked to teach something that is clearly immoral or
being asked to
Write down the wrong numbers in a way that this is how we want it to look the bottom line
But actually it's not what it actually is
Whatever it is in your particular working situation when that happens
We have to say with the apostles in acts chapter four verse 29
We must obey god rather than man
But in the ordinary course of things doing our job
Is part of our obedience to god so it affects your obligations, but also your motivations
So that's the second thing
So remembering that you are working for christ gives you a new motivation in work
One of what motivates you when you're going to your place of work
Could be money
If you're there for the paycheck
It could be the impact that you're making like you're there to make a difference could be a sense of belonging
It could be self actualization or ambition
Could be fear
Could be a love for your family
Whatever it is. It's probably a complex mix of things for for most of us
But whatever it is christ should be at the center of our motivations at work
So we should be doing
Our work as unto him
From our hearts so you see this in verse five and verse six we're to work with
sincerity of heart
We're to be doing the will of god
From the heart so when christ has my heart this changes my attitude and my approach to work
Because my heart is there for him
All right, so he's not just the boss who's given me the task to do like i'm wanting to do what is pleasing to him
So the word sincerity conveys the idea of singleness of heart
So the idea here is you're doing your work wholeheartedly
There's a there's a focus that you are bringing to your work when you work with a sincere heart
So instead of trying to get away with as little as possible or or being easily distracted at work when somebody's not looking over at your shoulder
We are applying ourselves because we're wanting to to do what is pleasing to the lord in in our work
Our heart is for him and whatever we are doing
So verse seven we are to render service with a good will
That that means that we're not to work in a way that's begrudging but with a with a good attitude
Why because we're serving the lord bearing the fruit of his spirit
This speaks not only to our motivations, but also how we seek to motivate others at work
So paul says to masters in verse nine stop your threatening
So to just apply this to motivations employers or managers should not be applying
Fear-based tactics or coercion to motivate those who are working for them
There may of course be times when negative outcomes are a necessary result of somebody's actions or inaction
But fear shouldn't be the motivating factor of how we're seeking to
lead others
Our work should be done as an offering an act of worship to the lord
So let's all ask ourselves the question when it comes to our motivations. Are we
Are we working before an audience of one?
Somebody might say well, that's easy for you to say
It's clear your work is for the lord
It should be for him if you're you know preaching or pastoring or whatever
It's obviously spiritual in nature, but I tried to look at myself in the mirror this week and say like
Am I concerned about people pleasing or pleasing the lord and what I am doing?
And let me say when you've got a bunch of eyeballs
Looking at you on a Sunday morning
It's uh, you've got to question your motivations on what what is going on in my own
Hearts if you were to see me preparing for even this morning this past week, what would you find?
You'd find a guy who
Really wants to glorify god
Really wants to serve you well out of a heart of love as I'm preparing for this morning
But you will also find somebody who's scared of standing up in front of you and bombing and just looking like an
Idiot or whatever like you'd find somebody who's really scared of what you think I want to be liked. I have a desire for
Acceptance like fear of man is a real thing
So like there's mixed motivations in all different kinds of work
So we have to keep coming back to like
This isn't about how people are seeing me. This isn't about what I'm aiming to achieve. I'm here for the lord his
glory
Okay, so
What's driving you at work? I hope it's christ. So our obligations motivations, but also your relationships at work
Remembering that you're there to serve the lord will impact how you relate to your co-workers
So we're to treat our co-workers with respect
So you see that in verse five
It says bond servants obey your masters earthly masters with fear and trembling
So that doesn't mean like you should be scared of your masters. That's not what he's saying here
And this phrase is used a few other times in the bible
Remembering that they're not there to please them. So like they're not working out of that kind of fear
So what does it mean? It means that we're to be humble and courteous and respectful in how we are
Interacting with our co-workers or our managers or whatever
There's no place for being condescending or demeaning or or backbiting in how we are speaking
But what's perhaps even more shocking once again is what he's saying to to masters
Do the same
So you treat those that you are serving through managing them with the same kind of respect
Don't be threatening towards them
Don't show partiality
So this is remarkable when you think about the context, you know slaves being treated as property now here
They're not being treated as property. They're being treated as people who are deserving of equal dignity and respect
And he's he's reminding these masters that they're under the same master as their bond servants
So he doesn't take this social status into account and how he deals with us
We shouldn't in how we're dealing with one another either so in your workplace, whatever that looks like no matter
Where you said or where somebody else sits on the kind of organizational chart or hierarchy, you know
Whether or not there the the ceo or the the janitor that person is created in the image of god
It should be treated with the dignity and respect that comes
with that
So we must really learn to value others and to appreciate the work that they do
And to express that and how we speak to them the things we say to them
Lastly
Going to work to serve the lord also impacts your expectations
Your obligations motivations relationships and expectations. Let's read verse eight again
So our service is to be with a good will as to the lord and not to man knowing
That whatever good anyone does
This he will receive back from the lord whether he is bond servant or
free
The slaves at the time were not entitled to any compensation
So imagine hearing this sitting in the church
In the encouragement this could bring if if you really take hold of what paul is saying here
Now some of them were being treated better than others and some were given wages, but it was minimal
Paul is reminding them that whatever they are getting for their work or even
Or whatever they are not getting for their work the lord sees them and the lord will reward them
That doesn't mean that they've somehow earned god's favor by their work. No, it's
That's given to us freely in christ. It's a it's a gift of grace
But it does mean that whatever your working environment is like it will be worth it in the end when we are with the lord
Whatever we're not getting out of our work. We don't look to our work for that. We look to the lord
And we can know that one day we will be in with him and every longing that we have will be satisfied and every every gap
That was there will be filled we will
Be in the place where there is fullness of joy and pleasure forever more
In his very presence as it says in psalm 16 11
So that is the reward that is coming
In colossians chapter 3 in verse 24 says this it's a it's a parallel passage really to what he's saying here in Ephesians as well
He says that they're to do this knowing that you will receive the inheritance as your reward
That word inheritance makes it clear that it has eternity in view here
So god provides what we need. Yes often. He does that through a paycheck
But instead of working purely with our pay in view we work with eternity in view
We should live and work in the insurer in the assurance and satisfaction of what is to come
We work out of a sense of hope and an eternal perspective. So
If you're paid poorly not being treated well, you can take comfort in knowing
That the lord sees you he will take care for you take care of you and there is
More good stored up for you than you can imagine
So look up second chrithians chapter 4 and verses 17 and 18 there you'll see
Yeah, we experience afflictions in this life
But there is a a weight of glory that is to come that is far greater than any affliction we experienced here
So you can work looking to that weight of glory that is to come
But if you are paid well, you are being treated well
We can be generous with others knowing that our home isn't here
We're not setting our hopes in what we're getting out of it. We're setting our hopes in the lord and using it
To serve others for his glory
Okay, that's our expectation
We know the bible
To land the plane here the the bible doesn't just begin in a garden. It also ends in a garden as well
So talk about you look at page one. You see god working page two us being called to work and then the curse
But then you have the curse is done away with
Eventually you read in the last chapter of revelation a garden city being described there where the river of life
Flows from the throne of god and there's this tree of life that bears fruit
In the light of god and that it's there for the healing of all nations and there's no more curse
And there in that garden city are people from all nations. What are they doing there?
So what are people from all nations doing in this this final garden that god has prepared in the new creation?
Well, there's a hint in what god calls them there
Revelation 22 and verse 3 we see that
The people who are going to be there in the new creation
With the lord are called his
servants same word that is used here in Ephesians 6
And his servants will be there worshiping him forever
So we will experience joy in eternity as we work
And worship in the new creation
We will know the joy of doing what we were made to do for his glory
And how can we know that we will be there one day
Doing what we were made to do for the glory of god and enjoying it without any of the
Difficulties that came with the curse
Well, we can know that through faith in christ
We can know that because the one who is lord of all who is the master of all work
Became a servant
And he humbled himself as a servant
And became obedient to death even death on the cross
Therefore god has highly exalted him and given him the name that is above every name
So one day every knee will bow and every tongue will confess that Jesus christ is lord to the glory of god the father
We can go to know that we're going to be with god one day serving and enjoying him because
Jesus came as a servant to make us his own and bring us to the father. So let's pray now
But we thank you so much that though
Jesus his lord of all that he was willing to come into the world
As a servant
To come as a slave
Nor we thank you that he was willing to humble himself even to the point of death to laying down his life for us
Nor thank you that he lowered himself that he might lift us up to bring us to glory
So lord, I pray that you'd help us in life to
Do everything that we do as unto him
I pray that you'd help us to serve out of a heart of gratitude
to you
And lord, I pray that whatever vocation you call us to whatever line of work that we are in
That you would help us in the days and weeks to come to remember that we are there ultimately
to serve you
And lord, I pray that you would
Give us joy in you and what you've given us to do in Jesus name
Amen